what Elon Musk wants to do  is to promulgate and perpetuate  right-wing disinformation and the  Shilling for that type of uh that type  of content on Twitter  what his underlying motivation is I  don't really know and it's speculative  is it that he genuinely has political  views that he believes are best served  by fomenting right-wing disinformation  on Twitter maybe maybe that's what it is  is there some personal financial angle  that he believes would be served by  turning Twitter into some kind of  right-wing disinformation chamber maybe  that's the case uh could it be that he  is working in concert with I don't even  know who and that all together they've  decided let's destroy Twitter from the  ends I don't believe we know yet I  believe it's premature to explain  exactly what it is that is motivating  all of this but it is getting very very  bad and I don't believe it's going to  turn around anytime soon